[Musique]
qui est frédéric et laurent qu'est-ce
qui dirige les autres qui dirige l'autre
en sa paperasse et comment c'est souvent
toi oui c'est souvent moi un peu parce
que parce que moi moi je suis plus oui
plus aux autoritaire cessa de twitter
c'est une écoute parfois aux disputes
vous n'êtes pas d'accord quelques fois
où j'ai vu combien de temps ça sert le
2e 2e année vous avez quel âge
nous avons aimé parce que dix ans et 27
des sans couleurs à l'occasion alors aux
consommations qu'on a 10 ans oui allez
vous jouer tous les jours comme ça oui
[Musique]
je combien de temps je sais pas qu'est
ce que ça vous donne la musique vous
aimez bien parce qu'à parce que ça lui
passe le temps ils s'ennuient pas quoi
il n'y aurait pas eu de fuite ans en
légère hausse en mi ray mais avec notre
flûte on peut jouer à l'école ma soeur
on voulait duo légal allons roi dagobert
bonifassi jeu le parquet monsen
[Musique]
tradition familiale grand père depuis
bien longtemps joue de la flûte
traversière
alors ça les filets oui mais je croquais
pionnat qui s'est trompé font
sérieusement à huy non c'était ma femme
et moi grimpe à terre oui mais fait des
progrès mais il faut faire bouillir
pitois par cas présent tirs sur téva ne
faut pas faire pour montrer combien de
notre image que depuis
à quel âge que tu as commencé à faire de
la musique et sylvia combien dans 58 58
qu'est ce qui t'a wiki cette ut a poussé
one comme toi on attend d'ailleurs je
vous aime les glaces etc traversière qui
sait qu'il tape aussi parce que mon père
et ma mère a porté et pitt ait du mal je
vais bien fait je me dis tout seul
cherche-t-il ses méthodes
je me suis débrouillé tout seul
seulement jamais fait tout le temps et
puis j'ai toujours été dans une musique
ça me fait tout bien emballé pour gta
est vrai j'étais au lit là j'étais au
pré-saint-gervais bien portants c'est
tout 4,5
ça fait 20 ans que je vais apporter
[Musique]